in part three of this video series i'm
going to show you how to create a
vintage b-movie title that will make
your friends think you're a hollywood
pro
hi my name is cameron with motion
science this is the third video in a
series of videos where i'm teaching you
how to create an eye-catching
attention-grabbing sci-fi b-movie title
with a little bit of creativity and some
simple tips
so without further ado let's get started
on part three so the first thing we're
going to do is start bringing some of
this all together and making it kind of
blend in together so what we're going to
do is add a new adjustment layer we are
going to add a film effect now my
favorite film effect is under sapphire
stylized it's called film damage if you
don't have sapphire you can click the
link that's going to appear at the top
of this video that will take you to
another tutorial i have on how to create
a film effect if you don't have third
party plugins like i have here i'm gonna
go ahead and load up a preset for
sapphire film damage and i really like
this german preset that we have here so
we'll go ahead and click load on that i
really like how it crushes the blacks in
this and it just looks really really
nice next let's go ahead and add some
wiggleness to this so with that
adjustment layer selected let's go up to
effect distort
transform we're going to alter option
click on position and type in wiggle
parentheses
12 times per second at the amplitude of
three i want this image to
pop around like it has a loose film
sprocket and that's looking really nice
as well let's go ahead and rename this
effects and the next effect we're going
to add is under effect time posterize
time this is going to
slow everything down and kind of give it
just that vintage frame rate that we're
looking for so we're going to type in 18
and we're going to preview this yeah so
now everything kind of has that more
steppy look to it which is awesome
absolutely love it next thing we'll do
is add another new adjustment layer
layer new adjustment layer and we're
going to call this blur
and to this we're going to apply
learn sharpen camera lens blur and with
that blur radius selected we're an alter
option click and we're going to add in a
wiggle expression here wiggle
parentheses 24 times per second
at a amplitude of 20 we're going to make
it just blur out pretty badly here so we
don't want this to happen all the time
so we're going to bring our adjustment
layer to start here and we'll have it
end right here so it's playing through
and all of a sudden it just kind of
loses its focus and it gets really
blurry for a split second or two
and then it's gone so we play this back
you can see there just for a little bit
it just adds a little detail here to
getting a out of focus camera next let's
add another new adjustment layer and
we're going to call this transition and
we're going to go to effect transition
and we're going to go to gradient wipe
which we find right here and we are
going to go to the beginning of our
timeline here set a transition
completeness to a hundred percent so
it's all black set our smoothness to
about fifty percent go about 12 frames
in and set our completion to zero and
this is just going to be a really nice
transition and as you can see there
versus just doing a simple fade to black
what this gradient wipe does is it
brings in the lighter values first and
then the darker values so we'll stop the
transition here so we'll option bracket
to end our layer there and everything's
just looking really nice at this point
as you can see here let's add a little
bit of specs here so let's go to layer
new solid
and we'll call this dust
one and go ahead and solo this layer
here and to this we're going to apply
effect
noise and grain fractal noise we're
going to change the contrast to 1000 the
brightness to negative 400 and we're
going to go down here into evolution
options random seed
u
and bring this back to the beginning
here and then go to the end of our
timeline here and we'll put in a value
here of 65 and we've got some really
nice
white dust on black so now if we unsolo
this dust and we bring it down below our
effects and we set this to a screen mode
you're going to see we've got some dust
here it's very subtle but you can see it
there on the screen it's looking really
nice i also want to adjust a few of the
nebulas here so let's find out which one
is over here on the right side maybe two
go ahead and bring it down a little bit
maybe something like that i wanted to
create some more black space up in here
and then nebula one
[Music]
i'm gonna create a little bit more
contrast here in our image and the
nebula three is right here in the middle
which i think is working okay so the
last thing i want to do here is give
this scene a little bit more depth i
just don't like how we can see all these
asteroids way back in space here so i'm
going to open up the camera and i'm
going to go to depth of field i'm going
to turn it on
and i'm really liking that a lot let's
go ahead and change our focus distance
here so we can bring our focus closer to
the camera which you can see now this
asteroid's a little bit more in focus
it's always a good idea with this to go
ahead and go to full res at this point
so we see everything exactly how it's
going to look when you render it out
getting even better
but this asteroid that's out of focus
here is really bugging me
should be in front of our ship versus
behind our ship so what i want to do
here is go to my particle system
and it's all about these little details
at the very end and just trying to get
things to look just right so i'm going
to change my random seed here maybe like
one see if i can get rid of that
particle i also noticed that the the
text here is really really white if you
look at the rest of the image here
nothing is as wide as this text is just
going to go really quickly into tent
here and just
bring down that
value that white a little bit actually
that's too much so we'll bring it back
up a little bit maybe somewhere in
between
maybe just a little bit more
[Music]
you could also do this by just adjusting
the color of the text and then to the
effects i'm going to apply blur and
sharpen gaussian blur i'm just going to
blur out the edges just slightly so
maybe
two maybe three just to give them a
little bit of softness that's be that's
after the blur this is before so it's
very very subtle
i'm also wondering about not taking this
transition all the way to zero but
instead leaving it at maybe like 50
maybe
25
and just extending it the entire image
with out and with it just kind of
crushes the blacks a little bit more
which i really like and there we go
there is the finished sci-fi b-movie
title i hope that you really enjoyed
this lesson please let me know if you
have any questions in the comments i'd
love to answer them for you hit that
like button if you enjoyed this video
and please subscribe to this channel it
helps the algorithm for other people to
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro i have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv
you can also learn more about this
course by clicking the link in the
description as always thanks for
watching my name is cameron and this is
motion science
[Music]
you